creating a stubborn stain is easy
but removing it can feel like a nearly
impossible task
here are some tips and tricks from
experts for removing five of the
toughest stains like wine blood mold and
more
at hubert steam cleaning james hubert
cleans wine stains on carpets
he saturates the stain with a protein
remover that targets acids and oils
this counteracts the acidity of the wine
and makes it dissipate
he sprays the stain for about 25 minutes
and lets it sit for 40 more minutes
then he soaks the carpet with hot water
using the bonzer steam cleaner the trick
is managing the heat correctly
if it's too high it can leave brown
stains behind
if it's too low the stain will just sit
on top of the carpet
[Music]
at superfresh john bristol cleans
mattresses with blood and urine stains
he uses an enzyme-based cleaner which
helps break down the stain faster
he scrubs the stain with a soft brush
that rotates at about 600 revolutions
per minute
this helps break down larger debris on
the surface of the fabric
he might apply the cleaner twice or
scrub for longer depending on how
stubborn the stain is
the last step is to extract the surface
with a steamer
the heat helps the enzyme break down the
stain even faster the steamer vacuums
the surface while spraying a solution of
water
fabric shampoo and deodorizer
this rinses away the remainder of the
stain and the chemicals
over at wd detailing rj wagner and brent
decessor remove six years of mold from
this car's carpet
they treat the car with an ozone machine
which suffocates and kills the bacteria
so it's safe to work on
then they use a vacuum to suck out any
moisture
[Music]
they use a tornado attachment on an air
compressor
it shoots out compressed air in a
circular motion which blows out debris
deep within the cloths fibers
the compartment is filled with
all-purpose cleaner diluted in water
they saturate the surface with soap and
use an extractor to shoot hot water into
the carpet
this is lubricating the carpet for the
drill brush which massages the soap into
the fibers
an extractor vacuums out any leftover
debris and moisture
to ensure there's no mold regrowth the
surface has to dry completely
[Music]
already
is a house cleaner who works with sticky
and oily stains
here she's cleaning a dirty kitchen
she starts by scraping any large chunks
off of the top of the stain
lime scale stains are usually caused by
minerals in water
they leave white calcium and red rust on
surfaces
these stains require an acidic cleaner
like vinegar or citric acid
softer stains like grease oil and coffee
are usually sticky for those she uses an
alkaline solution like bleach oven
cleaner or baking powder
ari typically prefers oven cleaner over
bleach since it's less harsh
you